The term “comic book movie” typically
means superhero, but publishers have featured
much more than capes and cowls in their graphic
novels.
The medium has been used to tell stories in
several genres, many of which are then translated
to film with great effect.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 best comic book
movies of all-time.
Superman: The Movie
It may have been an easy sell, but the first
Superman showed that there was a bright future
for comic book films in the decades to follow.
Sporting an instantly iconic cast and well-crafted
thrills that delighted crowds around the world,
the movie was both a critical and commercial
success.
Director Richard Donner found the right tone
to showcase the Man of Steel, encapsulating
a sense of joy and awe at being able to watch
a man fly.
And even after several recastings, Christopher
Reeve is still Superman to entire generations,
and the standard by which all others are measured.
Men in Black
Based on a Marvel Comic, this film brilliantly
paired the hip Will Smith with the curmudgeonly
Tommy Lee Jones to gut-busting results.
Featuring a script that was equal parts creative
and humorous, the movie was a clever spin
on the buddy cop concept, mixing it up with
sci-fi elements and the aliens secretly living
among human society.
Not only that, the film surprisingly had a
strong heart, which gave the product, and
the leads’ touching farewell, some emotional
pull to suck viewers in.
That aspect made Men in Black the complete
package, and a world worth visiting in multiple
sequels.
Road to Perdition
A somber tale of a father and son on the run,
Road to Perdition delivered suspense and drama
in spades.
The film featured a different kind of turn
for star Tom Hanks, playing a stoic, Depression-era
hitman to perfection.
Dealing with emotional themes of guilt, damnation,
and protecting childhood innocence, the narrative
was instantly relatable and gave viewers plenty
of substance to go along with its style.
It may not be the easiest watch with its many
heart-wrenching twists, but Road to Perdition
represents filmmaking at its best, and is
one of the better gangster films thanks to
its complex story and characters.
Spider-Man 2
Long before the MCU had to save his cinematic
reputation, Spider-Man was at the top of the
superhero movie totem pole.
Building off of the original movie’s humor
and heart, Sam Raimi used this sequel to expand
on the same ideas and further strengthen character
dynamics, Peter and Harry Osborn’s relationship
chief among them.
The film showed why Spider-Man is a hero for
the everyman, dedicating nearly as much time
to Peter’s personal arc to make the lead
a well-rounded character.
Dr. Otto Octavius was the perfect comic villain,
equal parts sinister and selfless, with unforgettable
action thrown in as well.
A History of Violence
A title with many meanings, this film served
up plenty of food for thought throughout its
running time.
Director David Cronenberg used the movie to
explore the nature of the human condition
- and violence in particular – in captivating
fashion.
Critics applauded his direction, as he displayed
he was at the top of his craft with well-constructed
scenes and sequences that hammered home the
script’s themes.
The cast was top-notch too.
William Hurt may have been the only one to
get an Oscar nomination, but everyone from
Viggo Mortensen to Ed Harris were at the top
of their games.
V for Vendetta
Pulling off the tricky task of adapting Alan
Moore’s work to film, this Wachowski production
blew audiences away with everything from the
visual style to the heady concepts and commentary.
As you might expect, the set pieces were stunning
to witness, showcasing a grand spectacle that
demands to be seen on the largest of screens.
But what made V for Vendetta stand out was
its story, which explored the restlessness
of a political rebellion, and just how far
activists would go to ensure justice for all.
In the end, the impressive work – and its
masked star – succeeded on multiple levels
and broke new ground for the genre.
Zack Snyder is best known for his unique flair
and filmmaking style, and much of that reputation
is owed to 300.
Combining an old school underdog story with
revolutionary modern technology, the adaptation
of Frank Miller’s comic was an incredible
technical achievement, which more than made
up for any narrative shortcomings.
Breathtaking action sequences that redefined
the concept, and popularizing a new form of
speed-ramping slo-mo were just two small impacts.
And leading the way was Gerard Butler, whose
take on King Leonidas made the hero, and the
actor, a fan-favorite.
Not to mention immortalizing one of his very
best one-liners.
The Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan’s acclaimed crime drama
became one of the crowning moments of 21st
century blockbuster cinema thanks to its complex
portrayal of heroism, mirroring real-world
dilemmas to a chilling effect.
The director’s brand of “dark” and “gritty”
filmmaking has proven extremely influential,
inspiring countless imitators looking to recapture
Nolan’s magic.
The Dark Knight also works as a character
study alone, led by the crazed anarchy of
Heath Ledger’s Joker and Christian Bale’s
focused Batman.
Aaron Eckhart’s Two-Face was a welcome addition,
adding yet another twist to give the story
one final push into greatness.
The Avengers
One time accused of being overly-ambitious,
Marvel Studios showed that the shared universe
model of franchise building could work in
exciting ways.
Bringing together a collection of their most
popular heroes, The Avengers set box office
records and earned much critical acclaim due
to the chemistry between actors and sharp
wit.
But it wasn’t just the heroes who made this
a marvelous adventure.
Tom Hiddleston cemented his status as the
MCU’s best evildoer with another captivating
turn as Loki, serving as the ideal foil for
Earth’s Mightiest in their first mission
together.
Joss Whedon was seen as a risky choice for
crafting the MCU, but these days, every studio
looks to copy the Avengers’ shared universe
success.
Snowpiercer
A breath of fresh air for those jaded by overproduced
summer blockbusters, Snowpiercer delivered
thrills and suspense that rival those of a
tentpole.
Using a single train to explore class separation
and equality, the film didn’t pull any punches
and gave audiences plenty to think about long
after the ride was over.
Grounded by captivating performances by actors
like Chris Evans and Tilda Swinton, Snowpiercer
didn’t short on character development either,
creating a rich environment populated by colorful,
and often freakish people and concepts.
It’d be nice if all summer movies could
be this headstrong, but the pleasant surprise
is what made Snowpiercer a treat.
Those are our picks for the best comic book
movies of all-time.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!